what does it mean to travel to discover
something new for the first time for
some it's to escape to have fun to learn
for me it's the feeling of wonder
walking through a buzzing city a quiet
small town a hike to see the wonders of
the world you can feel the energy of the
place you're in you become part of the
culture the movements travelling has
taught me a lot and I want to share with
you how it has made me a stronger person
my active travels give me the chance to
be active and stay fit while being
immersed in a new place when you train
hard and take on the new challenge it
can give you a huge sense of
accomplishment pushing you further to
believe in yourself and achieve your
personal goals
[Music]
when was the last time you truly lived
in the moment taking a break for my
familiar routine and surrounding allows
me to experience things again for the
first time I'm someone who likes to have
a plan and clear direction traveler has
taught me that sometimes I just need to
chill live in the present and let things
happen
[Music]
traveling has taught me to embrace
experiences not fear them making me a
more confident and independent person an
active travel will push you out of your
comfort zone you might find yourself in
situations we can't speak the language
or you have to navigate your way around
a city a village or even a mountain you
have no choice but to adapt to your
surrounding and this has taught me to
tackle bigger obstacles in life
[Music]
traveling the world has made me a wiser
person you learn countless things about
other people's cultures surroundings and
of course their food you discover new
tastes new healthy cuisines which you
can bring home and include into your
diet it is the kind of learning that
you'll never forget
[Music]
when was the last time you met someone
new active Travel connects me to
different people and most of the time it
is easier to make new friends because
there aren't any expectations this
allows me to be more real and open to
express myself with thoughts of feeling
Josh being away makes me realize just
how much I care for the people close to
me I reflect on the people back home who
matter the most it makes me appreciate
just how important they are to me and
not to take the little moments for
granted
trevor allows my mind body and spirit to
recharge in a way that is not possible
at home sometimes you can lose direction
and feel a lack of willpower through
traveling I'm able to reconnect with my
inner self and take a closer look at my
priorities and dreams
Travel can help give you the courage to
reinvent yourself and take the bold
steps you might have been avoiding
traveling can make you a stronger person
in many different ways as much as I try
to capture and share my travel moments
with you
you